no one should have to feel as if they
are inferior or insecure
high schools when you're trying to find
out who you are and try to find your
personality and your identity
you should never have to feel as if
you're alone going through that
[Music]
we all are kind of battling something
and we all have felt the feeling of
isolation
everybody should have a confidence to be
who they are truly
it starts with a handshake and what's
your name
coming here from haiti
i couldn't speak the language so
oftentimes i was isolated because i
couldn't communicate with others
especially in school like this three
thousand kids you walk out you see a lot
of kids just sitting by themselves
not by choice they didn't really have
the people to go up to them and talk to
them
no one has ever took the time to like
acknowledge that you know they're
actually there
[Music]
i usually sit in the hallway using my
phone do my homework my english was
really bad
i didn't know how to talk to other
people
well it's just it was so new for me and
i really was kind of having trouble
making friends
if you look at our school you will see
how divided the cafeteria really is and
it should not be this way
then we decided to start a club
we would start introducing ourselves to
kids who we saw sitting alone and didn't
have the confidence to introduce
themselves to people
i actually met a few kids that had the
same problem their english wasn't that
good so we started making friends
it's really kind of fun like be around
all like the really cool people here at
boca high
and they have pizza so that's another
plus side
that's the bond that we can all share
dining together building a relationship
with one another for anyone that's new
here today the reason why we come into
this club is to turn the school into a
community
step away from your friends you know try
to meet someone new the club kind of
turned into almost a welcoming committee
for new students or like for shy kids
the club might be an open arm and for
extra rich it might be an opportunity to
grow that leadership skills and for the
school it's like a catalyst for change
we're not just a club at boca high
anymore we're a club at many different
other high schools expanding out of
florida expanding out of the united
states
it's not about building a bigger club
it's about building a united club
[Music]
you